billions of people over the last 2000
years have spent a substantial amount of
time doing nothing but gazing at the
crucifix it's like why you know and one
answer is well those people are all
superstitious they believe in stupid
things like you know death and
resurrection and you know the virgin
birth and all those things that make no
empirical sense it's like yeah well
think again you know it's not a matter
of simplistic belief it's a matter of
belief structures that are so profound
that you can't articulate them you don't
know what they mean and so to gaze on
the figure of the dying and resurrecting
hero is to understand that a huge part
of what redeems you in life from evil
and from the things that terrify you is
your capacity to let go of things that
are outmoded and dead and to revitalize
them as a consequence of new learning
and it's the very soul it's your very
soul it's the very it's the it's the
living part of you and that's the part
the thing that's so interesting about
this is according to the to the wisdom
traditions of mankind that's the part of
your spirit that protects you against
fear and pain because you might say well
you know if you don't want fear and you
don't want pain you should build a big
wall around yourself and wrap yourself
up in styrofoam and sit right in the
middle you know where nothing bad is
ever going to happen to you but you know
first of all that's obviously ridiculous
and second of all you die of boredom in
no time flat if you did that you cannot
be protected from the things that
frighten you and hurt you but if you
identify with the part of your being
that has the capacity for transformation
then you're always pretend you're always
you're always the equal of what it is
that's opposing you or maybe more than
the equal of it so you can either depend
on the walls that protect you from
things and so those could be like actual
walls or cultural walls or totalitarian
beliefs or rigid thought patterns or
anything like that or you can rely
instead on the part of you that's
voluntarily able to confront things that
are frightening and painful and triumphs
and the the deepest story of of
humankind is that that's the part of us
that's the most powerful you know weak
as we are and some
as we are to all sorts of terrible
things